he was a legend among the stars tonight
we celebrate the triumphant life and
legacy of the greatest of all time
sidney poitier welcome to entertainment
tonight and we are standing by mr porter
a star here on the hollywood walk of
fame he was a man of elegance grace and
dignity and
hollywood has lost an icon
i can pull that fat cat down i can bring
him right off this hill
do you know that that money that money
is made out of my father's flesh i've
had more than most actors i have had the
opportunity to work in films that
transcended their times
mom this is john
it is my nature to make the kind of film
that would make a comment i'm pleased to
meet you mr strange there are great
actors and there are important actors
sidney poitier was both how did i break
through i think i had
great good luck on my side and i also
think i came along historically at the
right time
it is a long journey to this moment
this was our last glimpse of sydney he
was using a cane and leaving a west
hollywood restaurant in 2018. the 94
year old icon passed away in the bahamas
where he was raised our country
is in mourning i've instructed that the
bahamian flag be flown at half mast
do you think you would have turned out
to be as splendid a man as you are if
you hadn't had such a tough hard
struggle well that's a double-edged
question i mean you're first of all
presupposing that i'm i've turned out
splendidly i i know too many people who
would question that at birth city
weighed less than three pounds he was so
frail that his father a tomato farmer
built him a coffin but when a fortune
teller predicted sydney would be world
famous his parents threw the small
coffin away i left the bahamas i left
the caribbean and i went to new york
at the age of 15
and i survived there with no friends
no money no relations
no one
sydney acted in more than 40 films his
groundbreaking roles inspired a
generation especially oprah winfrey this
morning she shared this photo and wrote
for me the greatest of the great trees
has fallen sidney poitier they call me
mr tibbs
they call me mr tibbs i want to ask you
about sidney poitier's
importance in hollywood and i say that
in not just his movies but his position
in hollywood there is no one on earth
i
love more
there's no one who i have greater
respect or regard for
sydney was the first black man to win an
academy award lilies of the field earned
him the oscar for best actor and that
night in 1964 impacted a ten-year-old
oprah and countless others forever the
winner is sydney
i still see the image of him when anne
bancroft hands him the academy award
and
i was
profoundly
when i tell you profoundly i could start
weeping right now i was profoundly
deeply
sincerely moved by that moment because i
had never seen we were being called
colored people at the time i had never
seen
a colored man
look like that and i just thought if he
could do that
i wonder what i could do wow
and that was at 10 years old and because
he did that
i was able to do what i have been able
to do in the world and every single
other black person who followed
it only happened because
he was able not just to do that
but to be that
can you briefly recall for me how you
felt the night you got your award it was
extraordinary it was remarkable it was
like
it was great what can i tell you
what can i give you in return
some of his most memorable roles
included playing a high school teacher
in working class london in to serve with
love and a detective in the deep south
in in the heat of the night what works
of his really touch you i love guess
who's coming to dinner because the scene
and guess who's coming to dinner where
he says but you think of yourself as a
colored man man and i think of myself as
a man
uh that is who he is city was also a
mentor to denzel washington when he was
a young unknown actor denzel met his
idol in a bookstore i took out my
picture and resume
did you really sure did he was like well
son i don't think this is the
appropriate place he was young he was
skinny
then there was
but there was the flavor
of what was to come the oscars in 2002
would deepen their bond it was then the
academy gave special recognition to
sydney with an honorary award and later
in the night denzel won best actor with
his idol watching 40 years i've been
chasing sydney they finally give it to
me what they do they give it to him the
same night
i'll always be chasing you sydney i'll
always be following in your footsteps
today in a statement to e.t denzel said
it was a privilege to call sidney
poitier my friend he was a gentle man
and opened doors for all of us that had
been closed for years god bless him and
his family
sydney's final appearance at the academy
awards was in 2014 when he stepped on
stage to present best director alongside
angelina jolie the crowd stood for a
spontaneous 45 second standing ovation
the first time i met him at quincy
jones's house uh we had a conversation
and i was telling him about how hard it
was because i was getting so much
criticism from black people who were
saying i wasn't i was hugging white
people too much i wasn't doing enough of
this and i should be more of that and
and he said
this is what happens when you carry
people's dreams
and
after that conversation he agreed to
come on the oprah show
it's the one time in my life where i had
a breakdown after the show you didn't
believe the dogma you didn't believe
what people said was possible for a
black man
well from the very beginning i didn't
believe that i finished interviewing him
kevin and i went into the control room
and i
laid my head down on the desk in front
of the producer and i just bawled
i'm such an idiot he's gonna hate me i
didn't ask any good questions he's
he's never gonna speak to me again you
know it it was one of those things where
you meet the person you most wanted to
meet and then you felt like you were not
good enough
but after that he gives me a call
and he says he's calling me to apologize
because he did not feel that he was his
best that day
and after that we were friends forever
sydney left a lasting impression on
everyone he met actor stephen perry was
just 12 years old when he co-starred
with the legend in a raisin in the sun
he made it comfortable for me
with his sense of humor and warmth
i felt hugged
i felt his hand his arm around my
shoulder
i always felt
apart the only black people
on the studio lot was our cast
and the shoeshine man
and i can remember him speaking and
tipping the shoeshine man
and embracing
that person it wasn't just sydney's work
on camera that changed hollywood it was
his work behind the scenes as well in
1969 he along with barbara streisand and
paul newman formed a production company
to give actors more creative control
over projects he also went on to direct
his 1980 film stir crazy was the first
movie from a black director to bring in
more than 100 million dollars today
spike lee reflected on his influence
calling sydney a giant actress in
response to harsh words or a harsh
instruction tend to
tighten up and they have to be loose
sydney told et his happiest times were
away from the hollywood spotlight with
his family he was married twice and had
six daughters how'd you get my address
i'm nicole turner e.t was on the set of
the 1997 movie free of eden the film
also launched sydney's daughter also
named sydney's acting career it's kind
of mind-blowing in a way because she's
she's good
but whether at home or in hollywood
sydney was always striving to improve
himself and the world around him he once
said i always wanted to be someone
better the next day than i was the day
before there's always
room for improvement
at my age
what am i going to do
die
certainly i will one day but until that
moment when i am no more there is room
for improvement
you